[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Previously
on "AI Adventures,"
we looked at the Tensor
Processing Unit v1--
how it came to be
and its design.
It only seems right that
we now go back and check
out TPU v2 and v3.
What changes and improvements
were made to create these new
state-of-the-art chips?
And how can you use them to
power your machine learning?
Stay tuned to find out.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Welcome to "AI Adventures" where
we explore the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we're going to take a look
at the architecture of the
TPU v2 and v3, as well as
how the hardware design
choices come together
to create a powerful,
specialized, machine learning
chip.
After the TPU v1 was
created, the team
took the lessons they
learned and applied it
to designing the TPU v2.
As you can see, it's
considerably larger
than the first TPU and features
four chips instead of just one.
Additionally, it's got
some massive heat sinks.
It has 180 teraflops
of compute, meaning
that it can do 180 trillion
floating-point operations
per second.
And it does both training
and prediction now.
The layout of the TPU
v2 is quite interesting.
Each board has those four chips,
but each chip has two cores.
Each core then contains a
matrix unit, a vector unit,
and a scalar unit, all
connected to 8 gigabytes
of high-bandwidth memory.
That means in total,
each board has
8 cores and 64 gigs of memory.
And the matrix unit is a
128 x 128 systolic array.
What's special about
the TPU v2, though,
is its use of a new data
type called the bfloat16.
The bfloat16 combines the range
of a 32-bit floating point
number with just the
storage space of only
a 16-bit floating point number.
And what does the B
in bfloat16 stand for?
Brain, since it comes to us
from the Google Brain team.
Of course, you can't get
something for nothing.
And what we lose is precision.
The bfloat16 is
able to represent
far fewer decimal places than a
standard 16-bit floating point
number.
However, the team
determined that this
was worth the trade-off
since neural networks
can operate at a
reduced precision
while retaining
sufficiently high accuracy.
And using the bfloat16
enabled the TPU v2
to fit in much more
computational power.
Combined with designing
an integrated chip
and placing it on the board
with three compatriots,
so you have four
chips per board,
the TPU v2 achieves much
higher performance than the v1.
Now for the really
exciting part.
The TPU v2 is
arranged into pods.
One TPU v2 pod is 64 TPUs.
They're all connected together,
and you can use an entire pod
as if it was one machine.
And since there are
two cores per chip
with those four chips per
board and 64 TPUs per pod,
that multiplies out to
512 cores in a TPU pod,
totaling up to over 11
petaflops of processing power.
You can use smaller
subdivisions of the pods
as well, such as, say, a
quarter pod or a half pod.
What's really extraordinary is
when you start using TPU pods
to train up state-of-the-art
models on benchmark data sets.
For example, you can
train ResNet-50 in 30--
not hours, but 30 minutes.
And that's only on a half
pod with just 32 TPUs.
And when you look at the
training process used,
they're using a batch size
of 8,000 images per batch.
Quite amazing.
And this is part of what
allows that training to proceed
at such a breakneck pace.
Now I promised to talk
about TPU v3, as well.
So here it is.
As you can see, they took
the v2 and they made it blue.
But additionally, of course,
these chips use water cooling.
This allows it to take up
much less vertical space.
So the TPU v3 pods can then
support many more TPUs in it.
And a full TPU v3 pod comes
in at eight times faster
than a v2 pod and weighs
in at over 100 petaflops
of compute power.
Today, TPUs are available
as individual boards
or as pod slices.
And both TPU v2 and TPU v3
are available for you to use.
It only costs a couple
of dollars per hour,
depending on which region you
use and which TPU you choose.
Pricing for TPU pods is,
as you might imagine,
somewhat more substantial
with all those TPUs connected
together.
But for truly
large-scale training jobs
that you need to have run
quickly, it is worth it.
Programming the TPU
is just consistently
getting easier and easier.
With the recent release
of TensorFlow 2.0,
you can even use the
Keras API to code up
your training for TPUs.
There are great samples
and implementations of many
state-of-the-art models.
So what you can do is just
swap in your custom data set,
and you're off to the races.
You can learn more and get
started at g.co/cloudtpu.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures".
And if you enjoyed it,
click that Like button,
and be sure to subscribe to get
all the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, check out Cloud
TPUs and see how quickly they
can train your models at scale.
[MUSIC PLAYING]